Thanks for the charmful introduction.
Well yeah, my talk is called JavaScript level
9000, because I had no idea how to name the
talk otherwise and yeah, let's get started.
So, as he said, I was previously working for
Zynga doing the benchmarking stuff there and
putting out products like the Zynga jukebox,
but - after that - I founded by own project
called lycheeJS, which is something like a
JavaScript engine, but it's a bit more of
a game engine. And there's SkyN4T, which is
an artificial intelligence that is clustered
and stuff like that, it's something like a
hobby for me, and, I was previously also fixing
some Linux stuff, so I was also implementing
fixes for the radeon driver or fixing or supporting
the HD cards back then.
I got into V8 because I thought back then
it's hard to push out a game onto different
other platforms if they're not supporting
HTML5, so basically I started to realize it
would be much more awesome when I could just
use OpenGL there or use freeGLUT for it. Then
I put out a prototype for V8GL, which was
basically V8 combined with OpenGL bindings
and I was using it to cross-compile it to
other platforms like Android or IOS (with
the Node.app stuff). The advantage is that
you can even cross compile it to Xbox 360
or PS 4.
Basically I'm currently focusing on SDL stuff,
so my new runtime is based on NodeJS and using
SDL there, because that's much easier when
it comes to networking stuff.
So, this talk will be starting low and trying
to give you an idea how the data types inside
a VM are implemented and is focusing on a
garbage collection concepts or what the problems
in JavaScript are compared to other block
scoped languages for example.
It's trying to increase the level straight
and linearly.
First, Data types.
Primitives are the basic understandings of
data types and in JavaScript it's a bit complicated
because Primitives are also Objects, but they're
not.
So in these examples the Primitives are like
Numbers, Boolean, null and undefined. They're
Primitives and defined as Primitives. Strings
and Regular Expressions are not, because they
have a length property (and other properties),
so they are real Objects, but they're handled
as Primitives. I will explain that later.
The Strings are primarily handled in the Runtime
memory, which means they are deallocated after
the call stack is finished or after the scope
was destructed, and there's so‑called Hidden
Classes idea behind the implementations. They
use Hidden Classes to implement everything
for you, and the Hidden Classes are something
like the abstraction that you need for your
memory allocation stuff.
Aldo, unique static Strings (if you write
down the same String over your code multiple
times) are only linked as a String Symbol
inside the JIT VM.
Primitives, if you use the native constructor,
like calling "new Number()", then you create
an Object instance, and the Object instance
is handled differently than the literals of
the Number itself.
If you type like the y variable here (y = 123),
it is handled differently handled in the VM.
It is then no instance of Object if you use
the "instanceof" operator.
Arrays and Objects are basically all Object
instances, even the literals ("[], {}"). For
example, Arrays are an instance of Array but
they're also an instance of Object. Objects
themselves are always instances of Object
because the literals are defined that way.
The difference here is that the Primitives
are not reference-able after the scope and
the Objects are reference-able after the scope
was closed or after the Function scope was
closed and destructed.
That's basically the idea of the Garbage Collector
in JavaScript.
The hard topics is the dynamic typing stuff
because previously, before the WebGL Standard
you had no possibility to use something like
typed Arrays.
The idea behind the JIT VM was that they wanted
to optimize everything as far as possible,
so, in this example, both examples have like
the same values and the Array has the same
content afterwards but they're optimized in
a completely different way.
The Foo example here is optimized at compile
time because the JIT knows "Oh, the array
has this length and it's closed afterwards
so it's finished at this stage".
The Bar example is allocating everything dynamically,
so, at first (the 13 and 37 values) will just
allocate everything. After that, if you change
the type (0.5 value), it will convert everything
to doubles. That's the so‑called Unboxing,
it then has to be unboxed, converted, and
boxed again.
Everything will be converted to Doubles, that
means the precision of 13 and 37 would be
something like dot 0 (13.0 and 37.0) and then
it's still handled as an (un/signed) Integer.
If you allocate something differently from
the existing values like "true" - which is
an Object - then it will convert everything
to Objects or to references. I will explain
later how that is solved.
That's basically the difference about the
Objects and Array stuff in JavaScript.
What is also important is that Objects have
unique identifiers, even if they have the
identical contents. So you can use the deep
equals comparison ("===") and they will always
be different because of the identifier.
But they share the same Hidden Class behind
them, these examples (foo and bar) are identically
typed and have identical properties and the
Hidden Classes algorithm inside the VM will
use the same Hiddel Class in that case.
Hidden Classes are basically based on the
data types or the values of those; and the
order of the values or the properties. So,
for example, in this case, the Foo and Bar
example is identical. The Qux example is identical
when it comes to the values but the properties
are ordered in a different way. If the properties
are annotated or assigned to the object in
a different order, it will create automatically
a new Hidden Class.
So that is bad, don't do that!
Hidden Classes are also an abstraction for
Functions, because function templates are
basically (if they are constructed) creating
Object instances. In that case, Foo and Bar
have, when they're assigned, the same hidden
class of Point, but it will create a new Hidden
Class for the bar example because you're assigning
it a property externally to it. So the JIT
is recognizing it: "Oh, that's a completely
different thing and I have to create a new
hidden class for it". So bar is a fork of
foo then.
When you want to implement custom Primitives
in JavaScript, there's the concept behind
the valueOf() method and the toString() method.
If the valueOf() method is called on binary
operators (e.g. an addition), it will try
to find out its arithmetic value. If the valueOf()
method returns null, the data type has no
arithmetic value at all. It will be just 0,
that is the reason why when you add the Foo
and Bar examples together, it would be 0.
If you add another number to it (e.g. foo
+ 123) then it'll be the number value of 123
plus 0 - which is - of course, 123.
valueOf() is used for the arithmetic value
and if you return a Number value instead of
null - so it hasnumeric value - you can
add it to other Strings or Numbers and it
will automatically convert the data type dependent
on the other variable's data type.
That is the same problem with NaN (Not-a-Number),
if you add a Number to a String it will give
you a different result because it will be
the other way around before the conversion.
In that case, it's just like if you want to
add a String to it - then you have, of course,
String conversion from the Number, so the
Numbers and the values will be identical except
the types.
After the valueof() method is called the VM
will try to determine (if there's no arithmetic
value) if it's a String or if it can be converted
to a String.
That's reason why you see something like "[object
Object]" all the time when you try the dump
it into the console or something like that.
When you are returning an Object instance
in the valueOf() method, it means that the
data type is a high level Object and not a
Primitive anymore. That means the toString()
method is called and if you add those two
examples together or do binary additions on
them, you will get different results, because
the VM is just converting everything to a
String then.
And, yeah. That's basically how it works.
Now I have to dig into the Function stuff
and what Function Templates, Function Instances
and Prototypes are.
Functions in JavaScript, of course, have a
Prototype. The Prototype means there's something
like a Smart Pointer to the Memory.
If you have an example like this and are constructing
a "new Vector()" there, then the "instanceof
Vector" will, of course, be true. But the
prototype lookup (.__proto__ which is a non-standard
behaviour for looking up the Prototype Hierarchy
upwards) will point to Vector. Then (.__proto__.__proto__)
it will point to Object, because everything
is an Object instance. Of course, it's not
an instance of Function. The __proto__.__proto__.__proto
lookup will be null, then the prototype chain
is over and the JIT knows there's no inheritance
level upwards.
That's basically how Prototyping works. So,
if you have something like a new instance
from a Function, then, the direct __proto__
lookup will point to the Function.prototype,
and that will point to the Object.prototype
and so on.
If you want to implement something like Entities
(because I'm a game developer, I want to use
vectors and stuff like that), I'm implementing
a basic Entity and I want to reuse the Vector
methods there. In this case there's a problem:
You need instances on the prototype in order
to have it fully integrated with the JavaScript
VM. If I'm just pointing the Entity.prototype
to the Vector.prototype, I have the same methods,
but I don't have an instance of a Vector,
because the getPrototypeOf() method called
on the Entity instance itself will not point
to the Vector itself, it will point to the
Vector.prototype.
So, yeah, that's basically how the "instanceof"
operator works.
When you create a new Vector() instance, like
in this example, this is the way. When the
prototype of instances or the prototype of
Function template is pointing to a new instance,
you get the correct behaviour with the "instanceof"
operator.
So yeah, that's basically how Function Templates
are implemented in a VM. I hope it was easy
to follow.
When it comes to Hoisting and Closures stuff,
it's pretty important to understand hosting
and closures are not easy to backtrace when
it comes to memory optimizations. Let's get
started with that topic.
(...) So, the explanation of hoisting is like:
When you have a variable inside the own Function
Scope, but it's not accessible or bound inside
this scope, it (the VM) will go upwards and
try to use the next Function Scope on the
outer side (upwards) for that variable.
In that example I'm binding foo and bar, but
with different names. So it's the other way
around when I'm calling the outer Function.
I'm using the "bar" parameter inside the outer
Function as "foo" (so bar is inside it really
foo) and the "qux" parameter as "bar" (so
qux is inside it really bar). That outer Function
is a closure, but if I'm reassigning the foo
variable, I'm not reassigning the "bar" in
the outer scope. It will just delete the reference
of the Global Scope's foo. It behaves like
that because it's not referencing to the original
foo, it's always referencing to the "state"
of foo when the method was called. That also
means that "foo === bar" will be false afterwards.
(Next Topic) Closures
A typical problem is when you are iterating
over an Array with Objects and you do an asynchronous
loader (like loading an Image with an onload()
method that is called afterwards) and you
want to use the "a" iterator variable (of
the example), it will always have the last
value of the loop. It's like that because
probably the Asset will be loaded slower than
the iteration.
That's a typical problem in JavaScript, a
fix for that is just using a Closure to hold
every variable of the loop, so they have the
same state as they had when you wanted it
to be and you can just reuse the property
(or the variable) at that state.
That's basically how Closure work. There's
always a Function that binds the variables
to their own Sub Scope or their own Handle
Scope in which they are binding a variable
or a property inside their own Scope when
they would be free otherwise (after their
destruction).
So... that leads us to the following problem.
We need something like a Garbage Collector
because we have instances of Objects, we want
to delete them afterwards - because otherwise
our Memory will be totally bloated.
The basic knowledge about Memory Management
or Garbage Collectors are that we have the
Runtime Memory and Heap Memory.
The Runtime Memory consists of Primitives.
They're cleared directly after your Scope
has ended. If your Scope is being called and
after that the Scope is destructed, then all
the allocated Runtime Memory will be just
deallocated. How that works is not important.
It's just important that it's deleted afterwards
and that it can't be reused afterwards. Regular
Expressions and Strings are somehow exceptions,
because they have a length property (and behave
like Object instances), but they're still
treated as Runtime allocations inside the
VM. They are basically Primitives while they're
not.
The Heap Memory is something like the memory
that is available afterwards, but you're not
able to use it if you're not referencing it.
It contains Function instances, Object instances,
Array instances, and that's basically what
is inside the Heap Memory. If the references
that you use are not needed anymore and can
be unreferenced, they are cleared up by the
Garbage Collector.
You're creating Garbage every time you have
something overwriting the original reference
with a new Object.
An example is when I assing an Object to foo
and assigning a new Object to it afterwards
(var foo = {}; foo = {}).
That means unreferenced Object instances always
create Garbage and unreferenced variables
or named properties or arguments inside the
current Scope will trigger the Garbage Collector.
So the GC knows "Oh, I have to clean something
up". After the Scope was destructed, the Garbage
Collector checks if the references are still
there or if they need to be cleared up.
You can do hints for Garbage Collector, a
cheap trick is to set everything to "null",
it's non-referenceble and a Primitive. If
you would set it to "0" as well, that would
be a Number and optimization stuff is a bit
weird here. Just remember: if you have a variable
foo and you have an Object instance allocated
to it, you can dereference it by setting it
to null and then you can assign the new Object
instance to it afterwards. The Garbage Collector
and JavaScript Code Optimizer will know that
"This is the state where we can clear up everything,
afterwards it's a plain Object" and it can
resort everything (the optimized code branches).
That leads us to the Garbage Collection implementation
itself or How It Works inside VMs. I'm mostly
referencing here to the Java stuff because
it was one of the first languages to implement
a Garbage Collector, but most methods are
used in V8 or the Monkey variants of Mozilla.
When it comes to Terminology:
A Garbage is an Object in your program that
your program cannot reference anymore, so
it's not usable at all.
A so‑called Root Node is inside graph and
any direct reference your program can access,
that means for example local variables on
a stack or static class variables, like the
length property on an Array or something like
that.
Object instances are Live if they're not Garbage,
that's basically the opposite.
Live Objects (or Live Object instances) are
referenced by a Root or referenced by another
Object instance that is inside the Root.
You can detect Garbage by basically (...) If
you have a Graph where all the Nodes are referencing
each other, then you have to different ways
to determine if they're still referencing.
One of the algorithms is a Depth-First, the
other a Breadth-First search. Both of them
will lead to the same result. The Depth-First
search algorithm will go to each SubNode first
and then try to determine where's a back-reference.
The Breadth-First search algorithm will go
down the tree and look for references of the
Neighbors of each Node. They are both used
because you have two-dimensional linking Objects
(in the tree structure).
Local Variables are something like named Pointer
that is pointing to somehow anywhere inside
the black hole to a memory address.
JavaScript has basically only pointers you
can use, so everything inside your high level
language is only a pointer or a number if
it's optimized or basically the Primitives
and the Hidden Classes are the so‑called
abstractions for that.
One method for detecting Garbage is the Mark
and Sweep algorithm. It has two different
phases.
The first is the Mark Phase and the second
is the Sweep Phase. To determine Garbage inside
the Graph, it walks along all Roots that it
knows and tries to mark every Object that
is reference-able from each Root Node.
So your program will pause, it is completely
stopped. Then the Mark Phase is running and
tries to determine all Objects that are reference-able.
(Program Pause > Mark Phase > Program Resume)
Afterwards the Sweep Phase is going on.
The Sweep Phase is traversing all the marked
Objects and deallocates them and does all
the Garbage Collection Stuff. So it marks
everything and calls delete inside the low
level C++ code (etc.) and tries to free up
the memory as far as possible.
In Garbage Collection languages you have also
the problem with fragmentation. These two
examples are identical Hidden Classes and
they have two different properties with the
same values and they are identical. Afterwards
you're deleting one of the properties of one
of the instances. Then you cause Memory Fragmentation.
Fragmentation means Memory is free at this
specific address inside the Memory and could
be used otherwise.
So there's so‑called Compaction going on
that is trying to re‑order all the Object
references that are implemented "high-level"
and re-points them to new memory addresses.
(Oh, three minutes)
So, in this example, I'm having references
to (...) I'm trying to explain the references
that are so-called Handles inside a JIT Compiler.
It's basically in the VM something like a
Pointer to a Pointer. If you're using your
bar your foo (in the example) inside your
code, then it'll be basically a pointer to
another pointer. The reason to have it so
is that pointers can be allocated with a fixed
size. They are a fixed sized Memory Array,
so it's easier to optimize them and you don't
have to guess what kind of Memory Size it
will use later (after the compaction and resorting).
The Lifetime is determined by the Handle Scope.
Those Handle Scope inside the Function context
are destructed afterwards if the Function
call is over and they result in Garbage Collector
trying to clear up everything.
So, each time a Scope is closed, the Garbage
Collector runs over it and tries to determine
the references there.
Another algorithm to Mark and Sweep is Copying
Garbage Collection. It's something like a
basic concept where you have two different
static sizes of Memory and you have the Pointers
referencing to somewhere in your code. If
you are deleting a reference or creating a
reference, it's just copying it vice versa.
So that means for the Memory A (in the example)
it just uses everything it finds and uses
the first allocation in the other Memory.
Second time it runs it uses everything in
the Memory B and it will go the same way over
and over again.
The advantage is that it's super fast and
easy to implement because you have only like
ten lines of codes to implement it. But, it's
of course, bad, because you have so much to
do and the amount of the references is getting
bigger and bigger.
A Generational Garbage Collector, like in
V8 (or I guess in Monkey variants, too) is
using both of those algorithms and try to
have a Lifetime determination algorithm trying
to find out if your code can access other
Objects on previous states in the timeline
and if they're still referenceble or not.
If they are not referenceable, that means
they have a Younger age, because it's just
like one second old and it can be cleared
afterwards. Older Objects are the ones that
can be accessed any time, if you have something
like Objects on a Global Scope, you can guess
that they arealso referenceble ten seconds
afterwards. So that means Older Objects can
be used and optimized by the Mark and Sweep
algorithm and Younger Objects are optimized
by the Copying Garbage Collector algorithm.
(*Yay* 30 seconds left)
That's the end, basically that was the introduction
on how Garbage Collection works, I hope you
enjoyed it.
(Applause)
Also, I would invite you to Hacker's Lounge
for a beer and cheerful discussion.